six months ago
I watched with bated breath as NASA's
insight Lander descended towards the
surface of Mars 200 metres 80 metres 60
40 20 17 metres receiving confirmation
of successful touchdown was one of the
most ecstatic moments of my life and
hearing that news was possible because
of two small cube sets that went along
to Mars within sight those two cube sets
essentially live-streamed insights
telemetry back to earth so that we could
watch in near real time as that insight
Lander went screaming towards the
surface of the Red Planet hitting the
atmosphere of Mars at a top speed of
about 12,000 miles per hour
now that event was live-streamed to us
from over 90 million miles away
it was live streamed from Mars meanwhile
the two Voyager spacecraft now these are
these two almost unbelievably intrepid
explorers they were launched the same
year that all of us here were being
introduced to Han Solo for the first
time and they are still sending back
data from interstellar space over 40
years later we are sending more
spacecraft further into deep space than
ever before but every one of those
spacecraft out there depends on its
navigation being performed right here at
earth to tell it where it is and far
more importantly where it is going and
we have to do that navigation here on
earth for one simple reason
spacecraft are really bad at telling the
time but if we can change that we can
revolutionize the way we explore deep
space now I am a deep space
navigator and I know you're probably
thinking what is that job well it is an
extremely unique and also very fun job I
steer spacecraft from the moment they
separate from their launch vehicle to
when they reach their destination in
space and these destinations say Mars
for example or Jupiter they are really
far away to put my job in context for
you it's like me standing here in Los
Angeles and shooting an arrow and with
that arrow I hit a target that's the
size of a quarter and that target the
size of a quarter is sitting in Times
Square New York now I have the
opportunity to adjust the course of my
spacecraft a few times along that
trajectory but in order to do that I
need to know where it is and tracking a
spacecraft as it travels through deep
space is fundamentally a problem of
measuring time you see I can't just pull
out my ruler and measure how far away my
spacecraft is but I can measure how long
it takes a signal to get there and back
again and the concept is exactly the
same as an echo if I stand in front of a
mountain and I shout the longer it takes
for me to hear my echo back at me the
further away that mountain is so we
measure that signal time very very
accurately because getting it wrong by
just a tiny fraction of a second might
mean the difference between your
spacecraft safely and gently landing on
the surface of another planet or
creating yet another crater on that
surface just a tiny fraction of a second
and it can be the difference between a
missions life or death so we measure
that signal time very very accurately
here on earth down to better than one
billionth of a second but it has to be
measured here on earth there's this
great imbalance of scale when it comes
to deep space exploration historically
we have been able to send smallish
things extremely far away thanks to very
large things here on our home planet as
an example this is the size of a
satellite dish
that we use to talk to these spacecraft
in deep space and the atomic clocks that
we use for navigation are also large the
clocks and all of their supporting
hardware can be up to the size of a
refrigerator now if we even want to talk
about sending that capability into deep
space that refrigerator needs to shrink
down into something that can fit inside
the produce drawer so why does this
matter
well let's revisit one of our intrepid
explorers Voyager 1 Voyager 1 is just
over 13 billion miles away right now as
you know it took over 40 years to get
there and it takes a signal traveling at
the speed of light over 40 hours to get
there and back again and here's the
thing about these spacecraft they move
really fast and Voyager 1 doesn't stop
and wait for us to send directions from
the earth
Voyager 1 keeps moving in that 40 hours
that we are waiting to hear that echo
signal here on the earth Voyager 1 has
moved on by about 1.5 million miles
it's 1.5 million miles further into
largely uncharted territory so it would
be great if we could measure that signal
time directly at the spacecraft but the
miniaturization of atomic clock
technology is well it's difficult not
only does the clock technology and all
the supporting hardware need to shrink
down but you also need to make it work
space is an exceptionally harsh
environment and if one piece breaks on
this instrument it's not like we can
just send a technician out to replace
the piece and continue on our way the
journeys that these spacecraft take can
last months years even decades and
designing and building a precision
instrument that can support that is as
much an art as it is a science and an
engineering but there is good news we
are making some amazing progress and
we're about to take our very first baby
steps into a new age of a
it's face clocks soon we will be
launching an ion based atomic clock that
is space suitable and this clock has the
potential to completely slip the way we
navigate this clock is so stable it
measures time so well that if I put it
right here and I turned it on and I
walked away I would have to come back 9
million years later for that clocks
measurement to be off by one second so
what can we do with the clock like this
well instead of doing all of the
spacecraft navigation here on the earth
what if we let the spacecraft navigate
themselves onboard autonomous navigation
or a self-driving spacecraft if you will
is one of the top technologies needed if
we are going to survive in deep space
when we inevitably send humans to Mars
or even further we need to be navigating
that ship in real-time not waiting for
directions to come from Earth and
measuring that time wrong by just a tiny
fraction of a second
can mean the difference between a
missions life or death which is bad
enough for a robotic mission but just
think about the consequences if there
was a human crew on board well let's
assume that we can get our astronauts
safely to the surface of their
destination once they're there I imagine
that they would like a way to find their
way around well with this clock
technology we can now build GPS like
navigation systems at other planets and
moons
imagine having GPS on the Moon or Mars
can you see an astronaut
standing on the surface of Mars with
Olympus Mons rising in the background
and she's looking down at her google
maps Mars addition to see where she is
and to chart a course to get where she
needs to go allow me to dream for a
moment and let's talk about something
far far in the future when we are
sending humans to places much further
away than Mars places were waiting for a
signal from the earth in order to
navigate is just not realistic imagine
in this scenario that we can have a
constellation a network of communication
satellites scattered throughout deep
space broadcasting navigation signals
and any spacecraft picking up that
signal can travel from destination to
destination to
destination with no direct tied to the
earth at all the ability to accurately
measure time in deep space can forever
change the way we navigate but it also
has the potential to give us some pretty
cool science you see that same signal
that we use for navigation tells us
something about where it came from and
the journey that it took as it traveled
from antenna to antenna and that journey
that gives us data data to build better
models better models of planetary
atmospheres throughout our solar system
we can detect subsurface oceans on
far-off icy moons maybe even detect tiny
ripples in space due to relativistic
gravity on board autonomous navigation
means we can support more spacecraft
more sensors to explore the universe and
it also frees up navigators people like
me to work on finding the answers to
other questions and we still have a lot
of questions to answer we know such
precious little about this universe
around us in recent years we have
discovered nearly 3,000 planetary
systems outside of our own solar system
and those systems are home to almost
4,000 exoplanets to put that number in
context for you when I was learning
about planets for the first time as a
child there were nine or eight if you
didn't count Pluto but now there are
four thousand it is estimated that Dark
Matter makes up about 96% of our
universe and we don't even know what it
is
all of the science returned from all of
our deep space missions combined is just
the single drop of knowledge in a vast
ocean of questions and if we want to
learn more to discover more to
understand more then we need to explore
more the ability to accurately keep time
in deep space will revolutionize the way
that we can explore this universe and it
just be one of the keys to unlocking
some of those secrets that she holds so
dear thank you
[Applause]